trump spotted down for what appears to
be a contentious chat with piers morgan
who uh used to be his friend he was on
the
as close to a friend as donald trump has
i guess but
so now there's debate about whether it's
contentious because trump claims he
enjoyed the interview and that his words
are being twisted to make it seem like
he didn't pierce morgan says he got
trump got mad and walked out of the
interview he has video that seems to
support that and the promo they made i
have to hand it to him it does make you
want to watch okay pierce i'm ready the
most explosive interview of the year
i'll be completely straight to your face
i think i'm a very honest man much more
honest than you are president trump has
never been sweatier really
he's sopping wet and hopping mad it
wasn't free of fear he lost only a four
would thank you
i do know an interview so heated trump
starts melting excuse me with
history's two greasiest men go
head-to-head
[Applause]
monday after an all-new episode of
[Applause]